it's a rapidly growing part of town you
know at the southwest valley with more
and more people moving to that area it
means more businesses are opening up too
sally jaramillo joining us now live near
buffalo in the 215 and sally some
popular stores expected to be built
during the coming years
denise we are all familiar with the ikea
by the 2 15 now as you can see right
behind this area it's going to look a
lot different in the coming year with
more housing shopping restaurants gyms
and offices
hassan chaudhry is the founder for
global commercial advisors he says they
have a couple businesses around the
valley but now want to focus on the
southwest part of town their next
project will be on buffalo and bermuda
right off the 215 five acres of retail
chaudri says they are looking to include
a gas station couple of drive-through
restaurants and medical offices
southwest of town has been very busy for
last three to five years and i think so
covid 2020 gave us a little bit pulled
back but again you have seen that some
retail market is picking up chaudry says
companies are looking to expand in
nevada with growth in the southwest
valley there is also a demand for
specific services
back out live chadri tells me they are
still in the negotiation process but
would share the names of the businesses
within the next 45 to 60 days for now
reporting live in the southwest part of
the valley sally caramillo live local
now